like I didn't realize a relationship
could be this easy and that it I could
be that happy with somebody like it's
just so easy we have just a really
really healthy communication healthy
relationship and we build each other up
the whole crazy thing about this whole
bachelor world is it like guts you up it
opens you and you talk about everything
and anything and you become comfortable
with yourself your emotions and know
what we want we know we don't want
[Laughter]
together you've got a dog together
yesterday we had lunch in LA it's the
table next to us is doing wedding
planning Kalin's like looking over there
I'm looking over there we're talking
also and Caitlyn's on Pinterest looking
at different rings okay that sounded
kind of cool do you know what kind of
ring you want oh yes Wow okay all right
great well what I really like is just a
simple band with a daddy rock big fatty
rock and a simple band yeah and we
talked about kids oh yeah we just talked
about the what we're gonna I just feel
like we're such a good team where I want
to come up with all these like you know
the wine label that's coming out in the
scrunchies and I work with my team and
I'd like to think of myself as like
having a creative mind where he's like
the brains not smart he's where is this
II yeah he's very business he and I just
feel like we work really well together
and it's there there's no competition
it's like we're both just super happy
for each other when we have things going
on and we help each other more than than
feel like there's any kind of
competition
[Music]